one of the ways to have more time to do
the things that you want is to get
things that you have to do
done a lot faster and because between my
medical school and my various jobs
i have a lot of things that i have to do
every single day
i am quite invested in finding ways to
get all of that done
a lot quicker so in this video i'm going
to be sharing five ways in which i make
my workflow with
my macbook a lot faster and therefore
how i have more time to do the things
that i want like at this video if you're
interested let's get straight into it
the first thing i do and i have my
computer down here which is why i might
be looking down
is to use text expansion or i'm not sure
if it has a specific term
but basically i started this when i
started my job as a pa
and suddenly i had all of these forms to
fill in and
emails to write so basically what i've
done is i've set up all of these
keyboard shortcuts that all of my
devices recognize
so that i only need to type one or two
letters and a space bar
and they expand into whatever i want
them to i've done this with my home
zoom link for example so that when i'm
texting someone over whatsapp or in an
email i can just write liz zoom spacebar
and then
my link to my zoom account shows up so i
don't have to go all the way to my zoom
and copy the link every single time and
also i've done it for everything so if i
press a
a i get elizabeth in brackets ali's
assistant which i sign off a lot of
things with
i have ali's address here my personal
address my phone number adi's phone
number
so basically all of the things that i
just know that i'm using very very often
i'll just have a text expansion for or
for example when i'm writing an essay
let's say i'm writing an essay on
pneumothoraxes and i know that i have to
write the
word pneumothorax a thousand times i can
just make a keyboard shortcut for
pn and every time i write pn which is no
other word it can just turn into
pneumothorax
so this is what i would recommend that
you do it saves a lot of time
and it takes just a few seconds to set
up so basically to set it up
all you have to do is go to your device
settings
and then go to keyboard and there's a
lot of tabs on the top so if you go to
the second one which is text
you can add or remove shortcuts for
basically anything
um so yep these are a bunch of mine
unfortunately i can't show them because
they're all quite personal
um but yeah this is what i would
recommend that you do the second thing
is copy and pasting tool with alfred i'm
very often in this situation especially
when i'm working with studies or working
with large amounts of data that i need
to copy and paste things from one page
to another page for example and often
this needs to be done and can only be
done one by one
but what happens is if i make an error
or i want to copy something that
i've closed the tab for or that i copied
ages ago
i just can't find it so i need to go
through the whole process of
finding the thing again and copying it
again and i'm sure that if you work on
your computer you can relate
to having copied things two times ago
and now you want it again
but you can't find it what i find is
extremely useful is the snippets tool
and what it does is basically it saves
all of the things that i've copied and
pasted i think it saves up to 100 of
them so the list just goes on and on
so every time i want to paste something
that i copied three or four times ago
they're all saved on my clipboard or
when i know that i have to copy
like 50 things or 60 things i'll just
copy them all in a row without having to
paste them and then they'll paste
all of the things in a row if that makes
sense this is endlessly useful
and this tool is just a part of alfred
and then i'll move on to alfred too
because i think i think that this is one
of the things that
speeds up my computer workflow the most
the way that i would like to describe
alfred
is that it really empowers you as a user
in turning your computer
into a machine that you can very quickly
control from wherever
so let's say for example i am on this
notion page
for the script of this video and i'm
thinking i want to google something what
i would normally have to do is kind of
find go to google chrome or go to safari
open a new tab
start typing so i can google something
but what you can do with alfred is you
just press one thing
and this kind of search bar shows up on
your screen no matter what app you are
on no matter what you are doing on your
computer
and you can google anything so i can
google um
what's the weather like tomorrow and
press enter
and that will immediately take me to
safari and
do that googling for me so basically i
kind of skipped a few clicks here
and these clicks really add up and it
makes the workflow a lot more smooth
so for example if i'm in the middle of
writing something especially if that is
something creative or something to do
with university it doesn't take me many
excuses
to kind of feel like i don't want to do
it anymore so if i have to
stop and do something else for the fifth
time the sixth time or the 20th time
i'll feel like oh you know
oh i accidentally had youtube instead of
google
or something like that and the other
thing that it does and i find incredibly
useful
is that it's a finder automatically so
it's quite easy to find files on apple
already
but if you just press alphabet and press
enter you can open any file on your
computer so let's say for example i want
to find my cv
which is always i don't know why it's
hidden within like 50 folders and it's
so difficult to find
i can just press cb and i have a list of
multiple
cds and i've been updating it recently
so that's why i have so many
um and i can immediately open my cv up
next is tech sniper now tech sniper is
one of the most ingenious apps out there
i am so grateful that someone suddenly
did this
basically what it does is that it
creates this snapshot tool
where you can click and drag any image
any pdf basically anything that shows up
on your screen
and it converts it into text if you're a
student you see where i am going with
this
if there is a presentation if there is a
youtube video that's talking about
something
and you have to kind of usually always
type
everything out and pause the screen what
you can do a text sniper is you can just
copy the screen and it will
automatically turn it into text that you
can paste elsewhere
this is useful both for students and for
people who are working
so as a student obviously you can use
these with your presentations and with
youtube videos to get information
but as someone who is working i find
this so useful with credit cards
i think that's the thing i use it the
most for because ali has a bunch of
different credit cards that i
need to use so for example if he gets a
parking ticket he will send me the
parking ticket over
and i don't need to type out the address
every time i can screen grab his car
details from this photograph that he
sent me
i can screen grab his card details from
the bank card
and everything is just entered so much
faster than it would have been done
otherwise
honestly it's something that i genuinely
use multiple times a day on a daily
basis it is so so
so incredible would strongly recommend
it absolutely life-changing but the
fourth thing i would recommend is using
shortcuts within apps
and this is something that i always do
so um i
use a lot of apps and i try out a lot of
apps at least and whenever i download a
new app i will always kind of google the
shortcuts within it
just because keyboard shortcuts make
workflows a lot faster kind of make you
feel
more empowered and make the workflow on
the app a lot more fun in general so for
example on notion i know i have a bunch
of shortcuts so i can
automatically create bullet points i
could automatically create toggles
or numbered lists or make text bigger or
smaller
small things such as just bolding text
or making text in italics
on and off with your keyboard opening
new tabs closing tabs moving between
tabs
all of these things i would recommend
that you learn and you use because it
just makes
your workflow a lot more fun and fast
also especially here i will emphasize
screenshotting shortcuts so um on
macbooks you can either screenshot your
whole screen
or you can screenshot part of your
screen or you can screenshot part of
your screen and save it to your
clipboard all of these things are
endlessly useful would really recommend
learning also keyboard shortcuts such as
deleting a whole word or a whole line
just make your workflow that's bits
faster when you are typing the fifth
thing is using free apps
and as someone who is a bit of a geek
when it comes to apps and i'm always
um easily excitable about them and i
will always download new ones and see
what they work like
so i will say that i'm kind of getting
to the place where i'm returning to the
og
apps of every platform so for example i
use apple notes all the time
and the reason i'm mentioning this in
terms of speed is that
simple apps that are developed by apple
themselves for example
are a lot more faster than anything that
i can download for example notion
so um and they sync so fast across all
devices
i can make an apple note on my phone
which will be automatically synced with
my laptop which will be automatically
also
synced with my mac so the workflow
between apps is super super fast
sometimes if my airdrop is not working
for example i will literally just
grab a photo and put it in a new note
and then i can open another device and
the photo will appear there
almost instantaneously so these apps are
super super
useful um they're there they're free i
mean free after you've paid for two
thousand pound device but
um free at that point and they are super
fast and
effective so there's no need i think to
always look for the new fancy shiny app
but you can use the simple ones that are
there already and they actually work
super super well and i'll just have one
last bonus thing which is typing fast of
course you can imagine
that if your typing speed is 30 bringing
that tapping speed up to 120
would quadruple the speed with which you
currently work
so it's definitely something that is
worth investing in
of course typing is just a small part of
your overall workflow in whatever you
are doing
but it is a significant feat the closer
your typing speed is to your thinking
speed
the less friction there is to doing work
and therefore the faster and the more
effective
work can be done honestly i think these
tips can save anywhere from a few
seconds to genuinely hours depending on
how much time you spend
working or studying on your computer but
the most important thing i think is that
they
make work feel a lot more fun and
honestly just having a few more seconds
or minutes or hours in a day
to do absolutely nothing or to
procrastinate is
usually a lot more usually is a lot
better in the long run so that was
absolutely everything i had to share
today i hope you found this video
valuable
thank you for making it so far if you
did i hope you have a wonderful rest of
your day be count yourself and others
and don't believe everything you think
thanks
bye